jackie was trying to make a new start
who sat in the car well that's Tiffany I
can't wait for you to meet her when her
ex-husband drops a bombshell didn't even
know you're dating or not anymore
she seems young she's so much fun thank
you so much for having us where's her
family now right
they let me drop French just like you
said let her have fun let's high school
for one education how I think that kids
can make their own decision well when
you have a daughter you can let her do
whatever you want
para nada would you mind cleaning the
rest of this up no Jackie must discover
the truth behind the stranger who was
trying to take her place
she doesn't want me at home anymore she
just needs some space what do you even
know about Tiffany she's a good person
she's the only one who will actually
tell me what's going on what's just what
happened here it's fine that she didn't
mean to you put your hands on my wife I
most certainly did not
I know what you're doing what are you
doing in my room
hey baby sweetie protect you
Mitch take Brooke and get out of the
house
don't tell Tiffany just go
Mar Vista entertainment presents Annie
Wersching Kimberly Crossman Kennedy
Tucker and Tyler Christopher just shame
cuz it started so well given the perfect
little daughter she's the other mother
you